tis the season to be jolly it's also the
season to be fat maybe the average
person will only gain one pound over the
holiday season unfortunately they are
not likely to ever lose it according to
the New England Journal of Medicine if
you're already overweight you're likely
to gain upwards of five pounds over the
holiday season from fat bellies to fat
wallets 71% of Americans buy holiday
gifts spending an average of eight
hundred and thirty dollars per person
totaling six hundred and sixteen point
nine billion dollars in retail spending
in November and December that's more
than half of our government's 1.1
trillion dollar budget and more money
spent than on these sectors combined 95
percent of Americans are even planning
to buy gifts for their pets not all
animals are so lucky reindeer meat is a
delicacy in finland the demands so
outweighs the supply that extra
slaughtered reindeer are shipped in from
Russia and something you may not know
male reindeer shed their antlers in
winter so the reindeers who run santa's
show or FEMA and they're probably making
70 cents on the dollar 72 percent of
Americans believe in Santa when they
were kids but only 31 percent keep the
lie up with their own children
I guess that's progress while Christmas
is a boon for the Grinch it's not the
greatest time to be The Lorax nearly 83
million trees are chopped down across
North America and Europe every year and
it takes between 7 to 10 years to grow a
Christmas tree back Christmas tree fires
account for an average of 17 point 5
million dollars worth of property damage
every season the average household will
waste 367 dollars in energy costs on
Christmas lights and an estimated
311 people will suffer injuries putting
them up or down another big holiday
waster the two point six five billion
Christmas cards sold each year in the US
could fill a football field ten stories
high with all about sadness it's no
wonder that the two weeks before
Christmas has when couples are most
likely to break up during media's but
because we love a happy ending December
25th is the day that keeps us together
according to Facebook on Christmas Day
there are 34% more new relationship
status update than breakups happy
holidays